شكرا كريمه ابدت وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه
استعدادها لانهاء المفاوضات النوويه شريطه
مراعاه ما سمتها خطوطها الحمر وقال
المتحدث باسم الوزاره ناصر كنعاني في
مؤتمر صحفي اليوم ان استعداد بلاده لذلك
لن يبقى للابد واضافه كنعاني ان الغربه
يخطئ اذا اعتقد ان بامكانه ان ينتزع
تنازلات من ايران في المفاوضات النوويه
عبر الضغوط السياسيه وفي موضوع اخر اعتبر
كنعاني ان ايران لا تعيره اهتماما
لتهديدات الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده لا
في ثاني الى ان بلاده سترد بشكل صارم وجاد
على اي اعتداء حسب تعبيره ودعك عني
المسؤولين الاخرانيين لانهاء توجيه
الاتهامات الايراني فهم لم يقدموا ما يثبت
مزاعمهم حسب قوله واوضح ان الاجواء مع
السعوديه ايجابيه معربا عن امل بلاده في
اجراء جوله جديده من الحوار بناء على حسن
النيه بحسب تعبير
انضم الينا من طهران وراسل جزيره عمر هواش
عمر اهلا بيكم علقت تسلط الضوء اكثر على
الموقف الايراني
[موسيقى]
نيه سلطه الضوء على عده قضايا بطبيعه
الحال الملف النووي هو ملف ثابت في كافه
المؤتمرات الصحفيه هنا ارادت الخارجيه
الايرانيه ان تجدد استعدادها لمواصله
المفاوضات المتوقفه منذ اشهر بل وانهاءها
لكنه قال ان ذلك مرهون بمراعات الخطوط
الحمر الايرانيه وانا عارف ان الخطوط
الحمر الايرانيه هي رافع كافه اشكال
العقوبات وعدم ترحيل اي ملفات اخرى الى ما
بعد المفاوضات رمى همم ناصر كنعان لانه
تحدث في الخارجيه الايرانيه الكره في
الملعب الغربي عندما قال ان عليه التحلي
بالواقعيه ان عليه ان يوقف ممارسه مسماها
الضغوط السياسيه وقال كنعاني ان الغرب
يخطئ وبشكل جسيم حسب تعبيره اذا اعتقد انه
يمكن حصول على تنازلات من ايران عب يا ست
ادوات السياسيه الضغوط الاعلاميه والضغوط
على مستويات اخرى فيما يشبه كذلك الضغوط
التي تمارس على طهران في ملف الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا هنا قال ناصر
كنعانيان متحدث من خارجيه الايرانيه ان
الاتهامات التي لا تزال توجه لطيران بشان
التزويد موسكو بالمسيرات لاستخدامها في
الحرب على اوكرانيا هي همم هي همم ادعاءات
وهي حسب تعبيره وقال ان المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين عليهم من يتوقفوا عن توجيه
هذه الاتهامات وانهم لم يقدموا اي دليل
على ذلك واشدد على ان طهران ليست طرفا في
الحرب بل انها تدعو الى حال تلك الازمه
عبر الحوار بين موسكو وكيف استعدادها
لممارسه همم دور الوساطه حتى في اكثر من
مناسبه في ما يخص الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده وصف كنعاني التهديدات الاسرائيليه
التي صدرت عن عدد من المسؤولين بانها
تهديدات
خير وهاتهران الكثير من الاهتمام وقال
انها ترمي الى التستر على مسماه الوضع
الامني والاقتصادي الهشمس حسب تعبيري في
الداخل الاسرائيلي وشدد على ان ايران ردت
على اعتداءات سابقه اسرائيليه وانها كذلك
سوف ترد بشكل صارم وجاد حسب تعبير على اي
اعتداء اسرائيلي طال المصالح الايرانيه
فيما يخص العلاقات مع السعوديه وبعض دول
المنطقه قال ان وزير الخارجيه حسين ابن
عبد الله نظيره ال سعود وفي مؤتمر الاردن
الشهر الماضي واكد على استعداد طهران
لمواسطه مع الرياضه